les mariages tu me comprends kate tu me
comprenait allez remettez-vous ensemble
il yad'énormes problèmes par la boîte
les nouveaux proprios nous on spolie de
toutes nos valeurs et rin et
l'entreprise ma tension tht attention là
plus rien si on picoler qu'est ce qu'on
sait sur cette île exxon fondée par
vincent kruger réside actuellement un
pari tout comme air france ou non non
non non non non
voyager encore tous les deux pour voir
la flamme de l'amour vivre mon petit tu
ouvres ta question la flamme est éteinte
et tout fait morte elle est splendide
elle avec ti d'après toi une gauche plus
précieux que moi qui n'ai rien sur cette
terre qu'ils soient plus précieux pour
moi que moi que toi regardez-la cette
pierre est notre position
on devrait le volet quoi on est rapide
et précis alors qu'est ce qu'on va faire
un
il va falloir qu'on kidnappe 4 texan
avant de me faire passer pour eux qu'on
aille au mariage en septembre
parviennent à voler le collier sur scène
ça rappe sur trois ans et c'est stupide
mais c'est brillant
d'accord ça masque
j'ai espoir
tu veux m'en plus sympas depuis quelques
temps le 3e
quel moment
je ne suis pas en la faisant tu t'es pas
non plus obligé de s'en réjouir